KELLY STIRMAN: Hello, and
welcome to "Helping You
Realize the Full Potential of
PostgreSQL with Google Cloud."
my name is Kelly
Stirman, and I'm
a Director of Product Management
in the Databases group.
Later in this presentation,
we'll hear from Phil and Tim
from Wayfair on how they're
using Postgres on Google Cloud.
In this session,
we're going to discuss
why so many of our customers
are choosing Postgres to build
new operational
systems and what we're
doing to help address
some of their challenges.
The team from Wayfair will talk
about their work with Postgres
on Google Cloud.
So let's get started
and start by discussing
exactly what Postgres is and a
brief overview of its history.
Postgres is a modern open-source
relational database, originally
developed at UC Berkeley, and
its first release was in 1996.
While commonly used to
manage relational data,
it supports a more comprehensive
set of data models,
like JSON, Key Value,
XML, geospatial,
and many more capabilities
through its powerful extension
model.
This rich data
model support means
that Postgres is used in a wide
range of database use cases.
Databases created
with Postgres are
used in every conceivable
type of application,
from the very simplest
single-user database
app to demanding enterprise
applications supporting
tens of thousands of
users running thousands
of transactions a second.
It's found on the simplest
single-board computers
to the largest Linux
servers with hundreds
of cores and
terabytes of memory,
managing petabytes of data.
So why have so many
of our customers
adopted Postgres as
a database of choice?
Well, organizations have
started looking for alternatives
to the commercial database
they have historically used.
They've done this as a means
of reducing the perceived
punitive cost and
the aggressive sales
practices that have somewhat
soured their experiences.
But given the number of
open-source databases
that are available, why
should you consider Postgres?
Well, Postgres has a
number of attributes that
make that decision simpler.
It provides a similar
and, in some cases,
better set of functionality
than the expensive closed-source
alternatives.
If you're looking for a database
that supports parallel query,
partition tables, stored
logic, replication, change data
capture, rich data models, and
so on, all in a single product,
then look no further
than Postgres.
On top of this
impressive functionality,
Postgres has demonstrated
itself in demanding customer
environments time
and time again,
giving others the
confidence to use it
in their own applications.
All this, and a friendly
and engaging community
with a rich set of
tools and utilities,
has made Postgres an easy choice
for many of our customers.
But perhaps the most
important aspect of Postgres
is its role as an open API.
While SQL is commonly
considered the language of data,
and is indeed responsible
for the ongoing success
of relational databases,
each relational database
has its own implementation
with functions and operators
that behave slightly
differently,
and more substantial differences
in programmatic APIs.
What Postgres has the
potential to deliver
is a common SQL layer
that is consistent,
regardless of the database
engine that underpins it.
Postgres-- certainly,
its SQL layer--
could lead to a standardization
of databases in the same way
we've seen Linux change the
enterprise operating system
world.
Cloud SQL for Postgres is part
of Google Cloud's fully managed
database portfolio.
It provides fully managed,
reliable database instances
with features that
make databases
easy to set up,
back up, restore,
and provide high availability.
It's the same
version of Postgres
that you can download from
the community website,
with the ability to
choose between the version
of the database that
suits your requirements.
Google takes care of the
heavy lifting on your behalf,
patching and securing
your databases
with very little downtime.
Cloud SQL aims to provide
the best Postgres experience
anywhere in the cloud.
So given the many
options you have
when deciding on where to
run your Postgres databases,
why should you
choose Google Cloud?
Well, Google understands
the importance of the role
that open source plays
in the enterprise
and is committed to provide
the best experience for users
of Postgres.
We particularly
understand the importance
that Postgres will
play as a SQL standard
for databases in the future.
We offer a one-of-a-kind
platform to run your Postgres
databases, using the same
infrastructure that runs many
of the Google applications
you use daily.
You get access to fast
and scalable compute
and high-performance,
low-latency networks
with a global reach.
Google continues to invest
in its own dedicated
global network backbone
and standing up
data centers around
the world to ensure
you have the fastest and most
secure access to your data.
We will continue to offer the
best experience for developers,
whether you're building out
your own VM-based applications
or building them on
top of Kubernetes.
Google Cloud offers modern
APIs and frameworks,
whether you plan to
use Postgres to build
modern microservices
or more traditional
monolithic applications.
We understand developers
and are committed
to making your teams as
productive as possible.
We've created integrations
and management tools
to simplify how you make
the most of your data.
And we provide
rich and open APIs
to protect your
application investments.
We've been hard at work
adding important features
to Cloud SQL for Postgres.
Recently, we added support for
logical replication and IAM
authentication, making
Cloud SQL easier
to integrate with your
core enterprise systems.
Cloud SQL for Postgres now
supports over 140 flags
and 44 extensions.
We have tuned the operating
systems on our Cloud SQL
instances for
database workloads.
Google Cloud was
the first to support
Postgres 13 in the cloud.
And in just a moment, we'll
talk about Cloud SQL insights
and cost recommendations
via Active Assist.
Our database migration service
makes migration simple, safe,
and secure.
DMS is serverless, so there's
nothing for you to provision
or manage.
DMS will do all that
heavy lifting for you.
More than 85% of DMS
migrations are underway
in less than an hour.
And a majority of
these migrations
are coming from other clouds.
Observability is critical
for managing your database
deployments.
Recently, we launched
SQL Insights,
giving you best-in-class
database observability using
open standards.
SQL Insights helps
your developer teams
to understand
performance issues,
whether you're building
a monolithic app
or using microservices.
And now we provide
cost recommendations
through Active Assist, helping
you right-size your resources
and optimize your spend,
potentially saving you
thousands of dollars a month.
So thus far, we've been talking
about Cloud SQL for Postgres.
Now I'd like to spend
a few minutes talking
about Cloud Spanner and some
work we're doing with Postgres.
Cloud Spanner is the
relational database
that banks, game studios,
retailers and organizations,
and many other industries
trust with their most
demanding workloads.
It's the same database
that powers Google's
most recognizable products.
Spanner offers global
consistency and five nines
of availability at
almost any scale,
without painful sharding or
re-architecture as you grow.
Spanner's new
lower cost of entry
now makes realizing these
benefits even easier.
You can start small and
be assured that Spanner
will scale to meet your needs.
Even with Spanner and all of
Google Cloud's unique benefits,
our customers want options.
Spanner isn't the only managed
database service out there.
We want our customers
to feel confident
that they'll be able
to move their data
and applications elsewhere
without a disruptive rewrite.
The PostgreSQL interface
for Cloud Spanner
that we announced earlier today
will provide the scalability
and reliability of Spanner
that enterprises trust, along
with the familiarity and
portability of Postgres
that developers love.
We're making it so you can bring
your existing skills and tools
around Postgres
to take advantage
of the unique
capabilities Spanner
has to offer in terms of
availability and scalability.
So, to sum it up,
Postgres is becoming
the relational
database of choice
for the enterprise
for many good reasons.
We believe Google Cloud
offers the best place
to run your Postgres databases.
And we're seeing a trend to
make Postgres's SQL layer
act as an open API for
applications and deployments.
Now, I'd like to hand
things over to our friends
from Wayfair.
Tim and Phil,
please take it away.
TIM QUINNEY: Thanks, Kelly.
Hello.
My name is Tim
Quinney, and I lead
the product team for database
platforms here at Wayfair.
I'm joined by Phil
Portnoy, who's
our lead architect and
engineer for database platform
development.
Wayfair is a platform
that's solely
focused on the category of
home across our six brands,
including our marquee
Wayfair.com, and our specialty
brands of Perigold, AllModern,
Joss & Main, Birch Lane,
as well as our Wayfair
professional business.
We have more than 31
million active customers,
shopping a catalog of
more than 20 million items
from a network of more than
16,000 global suppliers.
Powering the systems to
make this all possible
is a team of over 3,000 software
engineers and data scientists.
When considering the needs
of our engineering community,
the use cases we
support run the gamut
from integrating the
suppliers to build our catalog
to marketing the
products and powering
the customer-facing
shopping experience online,
all the way to managing
the delivery of orders
through our global logistics
and operational systems.
To accomplish this,
our database strategy
is focused on providing
well-paved paths for our users
to quickly provision and
deploy database solutions that
meet their scale, resiliency,
and latency requirements,
all while providing a high-tier
support and subject matter
expertise.
Core to this strategy is
Postgres and Google's suite
of database products.
Whether it be single-region
reads and writes
for similar applications
running on Cloud
SQL or a globally distributed
system running on Google Cloud
Spanner, we have found
that Google's suite
of database offerings enable
us to drive innovation.
To share more about why
we're excited about Postgres
and the Google offering,
I'll hand it over
to my colleague, Phil.
PHIL PORTNOY: Thanks, Tim.
For me, as an
enterprise architect
for a fairly large
engineering organization
of a couple of thousands
of engineers and analysts,
technology matters.
PostgreSQL, being an open-source
and free-to-use product,
is the type of technology
that enables large enterprises
like Wayfair to have control
over their own destiny
in the data space.
PostgreSQL is a
proven technology.
Our developers can use it with
any architecture and software
stack of their choice,
without compromising
velocity and portability.
There is a massive
amount of learning
materials, documentation,
open-source guides.
And community support is
available around the clock,
which truly puts
developers first.
However, as most of
you probably know,
considerations about databases
don't end with developers.
Managing provisioning,
orchestration, monitoring,
and maintenance of physical
or virtual infrastructure
is a massive component
of operating data stores.
Google Cloud Platform takes
the infrastructure management
challenge out of the
equation completely,
allowing us to focus effort
and resources entirely
on product development.
Using open-source
solutions helps
Wayfair to transform
our business
in much more ways than one.
But there is one benefit
that's hard to overlook,
and that benefit is cost.
In modern, fast-paced
technological environments,
time to market is critical.
And PostgreSQL on
Google's Cloud SQL
allows us to minimize the
effort of preparing our products
and applications
to serve production
workloads, while significantly
reducing the overall cost
of the solution.
We've discovered that supporting
similar workloads on Cloud SQL
and PostgreSQL is anywhere
from four to eight times
cheaper than a comparable
commercial database
engine provisioned
on Compute Engine,
after accounting
for licensing costs
and depending on the
redundancy and distribution
level of the
deployment, of course.
On top of that
difference, with Cloud SQL
being a completely
managed service,
there are additional
cost savings
associated with
dramatic reduction
in operating costs compared
to deploying on premises
or in an unmanaged fashion.
This makes PostgreSQL a
perfect, cost-effective solution
for the majority of online
relational data storage
needs in Wayfair.
However, for some
distributed use cases
where consistent, safe
writes to the same data set
are happening from
multiple locations,
spanning countries and
sometimes continents,
a slightly different
solution is required.
That's where Google
Cloud Spanner comes in,
a truly distributed
and truly consistent
solution for relational
database workloads that
require distribution.
We're able to provision
distributed data stores
within minutes and with
almost zero operational effort
required from us.
Thanks to Google's
TrueTime distributed clock,
Spanner is capable of providing
the same consistency guarantees
as PostgreSQL at a minimal
added latency cost,
switching from writing and
storing data in a single data
center to persisting
the same data
points in a globally
distributed database.
And having the data
available locally
for clients around
the world requires
next to zero development time.
And with technologies
like PostgreSQL Interface
for Spanner, software
product journeys
can start with a local
PostgreSQL database
and shift towards Spanner
later in the lifecycle,
providing global availability
in an effortless fashion.
Back to Tim.
TIM QUINNEY: Echoing what
both Phil and Kelly shared,
the value proposition
of Postgres
is highly resonant to us.
It's open source
and cost efficient.
It has tremendous
community support,
with low barriers of
adoption for our users.
Google's investment in database
products leveraging Postgres,
from Cloud SQL to the new
Postgres interface in Spanner,
becomes increasingly
compelling for us,
because these products are
offered as managed services
and enable portability
to follow the lifecycle
of an application.
I'm really excited about
this concept of portability.
An application can start with
a simple Cloud SQL instance.
Maybe it's a proof of concept
on a Friday afternoon.
And before the team knows it,
it's a runtime-critical system.
In due configuration, you
can enable scale read.
If it grows to the occasion
needing global distribution,
it can be migrated
over to Spanner
without the need of a
significant re-architecture.
This saves us from over
provisioning infrastructure
from perpetual rewrites
of applications
and from the significant
overhead of managing
a sharded database environment.
For these reasons, teams
such as our supply chain,
catalog engineering,
marketing technology,
are already leveraging
Postgres on Cloud SQL
for some of their systems.
Additionally, Spanner is
quickly gaining traction,
their home services
and customs platform
teams recently adopting.
As we look to the future,
we're excited to see
what kind of performance
and operational gains
can be achieved as we consider
moving other systems to Cloud
SQL and Cloud Spanner.
One that comes to mind
that's particularly exciting
for us is our user profile
service, which is currently
on a sharded
database environment
across many servers.
This is a prime candidate
for migration to Spanner
and core to our customer
shopping experience.
And now I'll hand
it back to Kelly.
KELLY STIRMAN: Thanks,
Phil and Tim, for that.
And thanks to all of you
for joining us today.
We appreciate it.
Hope you have a great day.